Right so let's talk about Scrum and about managing your team, being in a team
being in a Scrum team and this material is
I think generic across whether you are in a co-located/centralized team or a distributed
team
and it's probably a refresher for many of you. We've all heard
bits and pieces about Scrum ... it's also material
that crops up in various places in the 169 course. You can't really hear about
about modern software engineering without hearing about Scrum and Agile.
Scrum focused on -
really - about the management side of things rather than necessarily the
software
components. Scrum can be applied more broadly than that
... the key thing that it's trying to do is help you manage
complex problems and effectively deliver quality products
whatever they are
at the end. I think I haven't yet
found anybody who argues that Scrum is
complex to understand. I think what can be difficult is actually applying it
and getting it to work.
We've got three main principles of Scrum:
One is the transparency; everybody in the team
... not that they are constantly bombarded with everything that's available but that they
can at least in principle
see the other things ... see what's going on. You can see the results of
meeting. I think one of the ... I mean you know in larger organizations there's a
tendency to say
right you know we should treat other groups as a black box. We
shouldn't be able to see
what's going on there. The danger with that is that you end up with
these bottlenecks on communication and it's difficult to get
get things done; but - so one of the Scrum principles is transparency;
actually with AgileVentures we go for global transparency ... because we're doing sort of
nonprofit projects
and so on, we basically ... we hold ... we live stream
all of our meetings, all documentation, all the code, all the pair programming, everything
is completely live streamed and recorded and we can see it anytime.
So yeah I think there's nothing like total transparency
to achieve total transparency ... to other things
principles of Scrum: Inspection ... you want to be keeping on
reviewing the process that you have because
it's going to need to adapt ...
the ... I think the whole
Scrum and Agile approach is less prescriptive it's less saying do precisely this and
then you will get precisely this result
it's a set of guidelines that say you know
... let's go in this direction ... let's try this out
see how it works for you and your particular circumstances and keep
reviewing
and keep coming back and trying to make changes and trying to get - you know - regularly be
measuring,
inspecting the outcome. Is it working? Are things working as they
should?
Are we making progress? So you know keep on making changes in order to achieve those
goals,
so in line with those suggestions when you - when you're doing a Scrum
you've got these particular ... I guess the roles in particular
so we've got Product Owner and Scrum Master along with the rest of the
development team whoever else is involved. So the product owner is
is going to be the champion for the
customer as it were and try and sort of take their side, try and
focus on their needs and the Scrum Master is gonna try and focus
on who's ... the actual logistics of running a scrum and these different sorts of meetings
in the Scrum
cycle and so on ... and then there's everyone else who's involved
and these ... the role that you're in whether you are just one of the team members, whether you are the Scrum
Master, Product Owner
as I think Dave mentioned in the 169 course you know that can rotate
and can change.  Different weeks different people take
different roles; it can be somewhat fluid
... but the key thing is this Scrum cycle we've got here
and the idea is that we've generated through some mechanism
stories about what it is that the customer the end user would actually like
to have available in their
product ... of course we're sort of focused on software here
but it could be you know ... that it would be
let's say for example you're delivering an online class ... that's
your output.
It could be that, oh I don't know, that you're writing a textbook, it could be
that you're
designing an advertising campaign ... we're focused on software here but
the Scrum is generic over all different types of
activities that you might be doing but so you get you know
ideally in the beginning sort of brainstorming; right we've got all these things
that it would be great to have
... you know there's a process of working out; right, what can we fit into
a sprint and we've got down here, is it, thirty days and that can vary
and its like what could we .. what would be the meaningful set of
features for the sprint,
for a single sprint that would maybe produce our MVP or minimum viable
product for us and you've got this sort of longer
cycle which is the bigger sprint cycle and then you've got a daily
Scrum cycle within there and we'll go through that in some
more detail in the next slides. So ideally the sprint
is between 1 and 4 weeks and depending upon your project constraints and this that and the other
it's gonna be ... that's going to vary
different times are going to make sense.
You ideally want to be producing some releasable
increment ... its ... if you're not
actually pushing something out that can be evaluated by somebody
on the outside of your team then it's not really
a sprint and you can if someone turns around and says "right, that
entire thing that you guys were building
you know, right, is no longer needed, right" then let's be willing to cancel it
anytime.
But so the sprint will consist of
planning the sprint; we think it should be one week, 4 week, what
have you
... then daily Scrums; crucial I think this is the bit ... this is my favorite
I think this is my favorite bit really of Scrum ... it's almost where the name comes from
is the idea that you have these short meetings daily and you just kind of
work out quickly
what's going on and where you ... coordinate people and
it shouldn't take very long and really what it's trying to avoid is like this period
where you might not see somebody for two weeks and then you find out that you've been
working at cross-purposes
that entire time ... actually obviously doing the work itself
and then there are things that happen ... you know where you
review and you do retrospectives and so on and so well let's - let's talk through
some of these different bits and pieces. So the Sprint Planning event would be
where you come together
and you decide what to do and how do it and
I get this very like ... it shouldn't take more than eight hours. I
think often people allocate a day
to do this ... depending upon your organization
this is going to be ... I think critically it shouldn't be that you
spend
two months working out ... a six-month a plan
it's right let's spend no more than a working day,
ideally less, working out what we might do over the next one to four weeks
and just sort of allow ourselves to
fail or succeed fast and keep learning and iterating ...
so yeah and I think I've a
little slide malfunction there. So the key thing about the
Sprint Planning event is that it should generates a sprint goal
and a backlog of tasks so
example goals would be things ... a description probably a bit more detailed than this; I just got
sort of short ones
to fit into the slide here but these goals would be
you know some feature or something that we might
add to whatever product that we're working on that's realistic
to achieve within the next one to four weeks. Can we get it done with the
resources that we have
available to us and that's kind of a guess and then also right
for that higher-level goal, you know a backlog of
different stories that would allow us to ... I guess that's ...
stories, tasks and so on.  We talked about user stories last week
... that would allow us to achieve that high-level goal
... so yeah this is you know an important
kicking off - kicking off the - the initial sprint in order
to work out what one is going to be focused on, and we'll see
more examples of this ... just debating with myself here about whether
to go
Pivotal Tracker which we'll talk more about the next section
but we can sort of see ... particularly like a backlog
of particular things in ... this is I mean I love
the public Pivotal Tracker access you can see
the backlog for all of the different AgileVentures'
projects there and we ... it's an ...
ongoing thing. So that ... when we ... I just wanted to link that there.
When we say you're generating a backlog it's ... you're generating a series of
tasks,
users stories, these chores that we talked about last week ... that's gonna be
... help you achieve whatever is your releasable
element at the end of your week or two or three or four
week sprint. So then the key things we talked about before is the daily Scrum
... so this is what you know happens the most
... it is only you know part of that process.
I think often and what we find in AgileVentures is - it can,
things can sort of collapse to end up just being about the Scrum; because that's the regular thing
that's where
everybody talks. It can be, depending on your organization, difficult to organize the planning
events, the review events
and so on ... but anyway this is
you know kind of ... I still say it's kind of the key
independently of anything else that you do ... I mean the idea is
you wanna be repeatedly reviewing what's going on,
changing approaches ... ideally it will only last 15 minutes;
that can be really hard ... there's these three questions
that you have, it's like, what have you done; what are you planning
to do and what, if anything, is blocking you. I think we might just add this in
so it's
what have you done ...
question mark log ... what are you doing
and we can say "any blocks?"
and this ...
done face-to-face ... there's this idea of a stand-up meeting to try and
particularly to keep it short and stop people getting relaxed
everybody stands up and you know they go around the room
and you do that, and - of course then depending on the number of -
people, does it end up taking more than fifteen minutes? And there's lots of like breakout
discussions that
might happen. In the distributed Scrum
... as we do in AgileVentures ... that's all being done
over Google Hangouts or Skype or what have you
... we've found there's an interesting
variations you can, depending on the number of people involved and the number of
projects; we tend to have
multiple projects on the go; is you can do a people-focused
Scrum or a project-focused Scrum ... I mean our
whole non-profit volunteer framework with AgileVentures
allows people to sort of ... there's no requirement
to be at every single meeting. People make time and they're
available as and when and so
depending on the number of people in the meeting and what's going on with the
projects; we might
go around each person and say what have you done? what are you doing? are there any blocks?
... we might say oh we've got quite a lot of, a large number of people, ten people in the Scrum today
... let's do a project focused thing and we've got about you know generally
4, 5 or 6 active projects in AgileVentures at any given time and we would go through
and the question would then become, to kind of the project leader for each
of those, would be
what's ... happened on your project? What's
... the next step and you know is there anything
blocking you? ... and then it moves towards this
idea of Scrum of Scrums, which I think as we're increasing in size at
AgileVentures we're kind of moving towards that but we're still at kind of this
intermediate stage where we're jumping backwards and forwards between people-focused Scrums
and project-focused Scrums.
Of course it's different in and organization where you know everyone is being paid
to be there and everybody has to attend the meeting at the beginning of the day
and you can decide on which ... the number ...
there is a much more executive control of this sort of thing
you know it's gonna be I think likely to be more people focused unless it's ...
you've got this sort of Scrum of Scrums where you've got daily Scrums are
happening for the individual developers on their own
projects and then one person like the - who would be the Scrum Master - would
be reporting back
in this sort of Scrum of Scrums format on the larger-scale
... so the challenge generally is keeping it to fifteen minutes ...
it does, I mention in the previous section, you want to kind of allow
well you know ... I wanted to say you want to allow about a tiny bit - a smattering(?) of
small talk. I mean I think that depends
partly on ... how the team feels about it. It depends are you
actually
all going to bump into each other on the water cooler,
in IM chat or what have you ... yeah it's a
... you don't want to be so rigorous with this 15-minute limit that
you fail to
work out ...resolve some little issue about the person having a
block.
I mean the key thing really is that ... for the -
for the Scrum with the five, six, seven or eight people or
what have you is that in principle if they're paying attention
everybody should at least hear approximately what everybody else
is kind of on at the moment and
you know if people have got any blocks. This is the key thing really is about asking
about if there any blocks?
Because you know if one person's stuck on using a particular kind at tool
and someone else and say: "oh yes, no no, I used that yesterday and I saw that sorted it out and
I can help you".
What you wanna particularly avoid is
then deep: "like, right, let's get the computers out, let's
solve that problem in that meeting"
No! it's like: "okay, yes, John and Bert you'll be talking after the meeting and
you know take that off separately". So that's this you know you want
the high-level; you want to get into enough detail so people understand
what each others' blocks are
but if it's going too far then that's the particular job of the Scrum Master
to make it happen; say like "look alright
yes that's fantastic we have connected you two. Lets take this offline and
... arrange another meeting for that" and try and move on so
whoever's in the meeting can (move on) ... because the problem is
that
you don't want to spend all your time in meetings, you want to be getting work done as well.
Another thing which is of course is making things happen on time
and this is ... the Scrum Master really
needs to work hard to make sure they happen on time and that
they are limited and ... yeah that
allows work to get done but
members the team to sort of communicate with each other and help each other
because what you ... when  you think about the alternative where you're
working
largely independently from somebody for two weeks and you spent
forty-eight hours being blocked on something that the person two desks down had
fixed the other week ... particularly in the distributed environment
... you haven't got quite the same bumping into people at the water cooler
... and so on. So doing the Scrum effectively online;
extraordinarily important. So then other events that you might have are the
Sprint Review event.
So once the sprint has been done and you've released stuff,
the idea is this shouldn't take more than four hours, maybe two meetings
... this would have the product owner
and also the stakeholders involved
and you'd kind of be reporting back to say you know what is being done;
what should be done next ... and
yeah you need to sort of demonstrate the product - what you're ... what you've
produced
and so you need to be able to do that within the time constraints, usually
four hours, unless it is a very complex product then that should be enough ... and then also how to
demonstrate it
without being boring. I mean that's just, I think you know ...
can people be trained not to be boring? I'm not sure ... its
you just ... need to make sure that when you're, for example, explaining
something to the stakeholder who's the interested
customer
you're not telling them all about the the details of the new continuous integration
system that you've got working
its about showing them the things that are important
to them and
yes so I mean as an example on ... what we have
... in LocalSupport, which is one the biggest AgileVentures projects -
we kind of have the customer meeting, I guess as our Sprint Review
events every week and so we have our
... we actually do that in always less than an hour.
It never takes more than an hour I think and I guess we're on a seven-day
cycle there to make that work so then there's also
the retrospective events which is
you know ... the Review event is sort of you're presenting to the
customer
the Retrospective event is more where you're saying right okay the methodology
that we use -
you know our Scrum seem to be going you know bleeding over to like 20 minutes 30
minutes on a regular basis
... you know I couldn't access the
backlog frequently enough, the management tool for
tracking about backlog
was going offline ... all these sorts of things I mean
that to try and ... you don't want to be you know
given that you've worked out some process to go through the sprint you don't
want to be blindly repeating that sprint
and hitting the same issues and issues again and again. of course
those things can come up in the daily scrum. You've got like
an individual block here might be related not just to the technology
that you're working with or some particular product;
they're to do with blocks "I keep on spending all my time in meetings and I can't bear it" or
what-have-you so there's an extent to which
some of these issues might be highlighted in the daily Scrums and might even be resolved
in follow-up meetings after those. It's
yeah a sensible thing to sit down
and review the methodology. And this is something that we have
had trouble regularly doing our respective events in
AgileVentures where it's a volunteer staff and we've got everybody
involved being volunteers, having their time constrained and so
its you know they can attend the daily scrums and - you know - and
an interested subset will be involved in the Sprint Review event but the
...
the Sprint Retrospective event is much harder to
... make time for, although very important ... we have with AgileVentures kind of a
weekly meeting which is longer
in one of the usual Scrum times which serves as a
planning slash retrospective event;
but yeah, so another thing that's important is a Backlog Refinement event
and at that's not necessarily a separate event but
you know you'll find over time, as we have done, that you end up with
things in the back log, a huge icebox a process of
adjusting all of these things and working out you know
sometimes I find we do this actually with the customer to a certain extent, because of course we're looking
at
the backlog; are these features still relevant
... checked ... have the priorities changed
and so on and ... fitting
in a separate meeting for this is challenging
... yeah but ...
I think the way we do it, at least with the LocalSupport project, that's just one project in
AgileVentures,
is that we try and have Backlog Refinement as a regular aspect
of effectively what's our Sprint Review meeting with the customer ...
... so I've kind of been mentioning
various aspects of the distributed Scrum. This is probably like you've all
heard about Scrum before many times, I think it's mentioned in some detail in the 169
course,
there's lots of materials online ... there's a fan(tastic) ... Distributed Scrum
there's a fantastic book from IBM with all proceeds going to charity;
a practical guide to Distributed Scrum. I mean this just goes to show that
Scrum ... it's not just
crazy start-up hotheads who are trying Distributed Scrum;
this is IBM with thousands of employees and
locations all over the world ... distributed scrum really it's taking the
whole Scrum and just doing it online!
It's as simple as that! I mean there are all sorts all those issues that come up
... to do with particularly ... time zones. I think time zones is one of the
most challenging things
but as I mentioned I think in previous sections and I'll keep mentioning it again because
I ... to be honest I am starting to find being a Hangout where everybody can
share their screen instantly
is actually ... I would almost rather have my scrums
online ... as long as everybody's got a good internet connection
... and you can see all of the Scrum activity that we're doing
online at AgileVentures ... all the time. If I just go ... I mean I've got a little
clip from the website ... basically we have
this series ... we have scrums and then pair hookups going on
just constantly really its every 4 or 5 hours
around ... twenty-four/seven at different times
and you can jump in and see a Scrum taking place and
this sort of pseudo scrum of scrums as we review, as we
work through
using Pivotal Tracker to manage all of our activities. So in fact one of your assignments
this week
will be to come and join in the scrum and join in if
you can with voting on some features for one of the
AgileVentures projects to see: "Scrum in action!!"
... yes indeed and personally I think
the combination of the Scrum approach the constant review
and the new technologies that allow all this stuff to take place online
is just extraordinary and ... its ...
there's a big cross over with the with the MOOC and the
169 course which I think has elements of this ...
there's an extent to which, yeah we may ... we're toying with
having
specific TA MOOC Scrums
... more on that next week
but so do also check out some other resources. There is a a free online book
about Scrum and XP there. This is the link there to the
IBM book there. There's also a technical paper from a few years back showing how
distributed Scrum could be extremely cost-effective and lots of other
resources
out there on the net ... so
what can I say, I think, scrum seems to work very well for us we're enjoying
developing lots and lots of features for our customers
very fast through AgileVentures and I know many other bigger organizations than we
are doing so ... come and jump in
Alright, bye for now